it will all hinge on what happens in the
war if if the war is a ultimately a
disaster not just a temporary disaster
as it has been here and there but but if
it's been if it's an ultimate disaster
that'll be President Bush's legacy if
it's if we work around to defeating al
Qaeda and the remaining Sunnis in the
insurgency and hand over the structure
in which may be the Sunni and the Kurds
and the Shia aren't real happy together
but they have a constitutional structure
and they're distributing oil and some
reasonably fair fashion oil revenues his
legacy will look good but and because
people will at that point emphasize
other positive things for example his
commitment to to moving against aids and
in Africa is really quite excellent
there are things that he's done that
like that I think that will get a
hearing if the war also comes out
halfway decently if the war comes out in
terms of total collapse no one will
remember any other good things that he
did